drapeaux en berne sur times square
l'état de new york enregistre un nouveau
nombre de décès record 7 179 morts en 24
heures
un cumul alarmant alors que la courbe de
progression des nouvelles
hospitalisations s'aplanit selon le
gouverneur andrew cuomo
les hospitalisations baisse et les décès
augmente je prends la science derrière
ça je comprends les faits et la logique
de tout ça mais ça reste incroyablement
difficile d'y faire face
chaque chiffre est un visage après tout
les mesures de confinement et l'arrêt
des activités non essentielles semble
fonctionner selon le dirigeant
l'état de new york et confinés depuis
près de trois semaines pour essayer
d'endiguer l'épidémie
alors que la ville en est devenu le
nouvel épicentre mondial comme partout
sur la planète
le personnel soignant se trouve en
première ligne susan est infirmière dans
un hôpital près de boston
chaque jour elle part au travail la
boule au ventre j'ai peur pour tous ces
personnels de santé qui sont atteints
par le virus et avec le nombre de
malades qu'ils prévoient je suis un peu
nerveuse quant à savoir qui va devoir
s'occuper de ses patients le maire de
new york dès de blasio a reconnu
mercredi que le bilan officiel était
sans doute diane inférieur au nombre
réel de décès selon les pompiers
plus de 200 personnes meurent chaque
jour chez m depuis le début de
l'épidémie ne sont pas comptabilisés un
chiffre dix fois plus élevés que ceux
enregistrés à la même période l'année
dernière